es precisamente ese es el debate
político que se adelanta no tanto en la
opinión pública sino también en sectores
políticos en conversación que tuvimos
con analistas políticos aseguran que así
terminará este conflicto que maneja el
país hace más de 14 días pero también en
la realidad es que para conseguir la
institución del presidente de república
se requiere de 92 votos mientras que la
facción parlamentaria hasta el correísmo
ha presentado 47 firmas y ha puesto sus
cargos a la orden necesitará de 45 votos
más para poder hacerse con la
institución del presidente de la
república ya las fracciones
parlamentarias 5 fracciones
parlamentarias han emitido su posición
entre tanto el partido socialcristiano
izquierda democrática han dicho que no
apoyarán en esta institución mientras
tanto el padre del partido pachakutik es
el brazo político de la conaie ha dicho
que sí apoyará por lo tanto todo
dependerá de el cabildeo político que se
desarrolle inclusive el día de hoy ya el
movimiento político pachakuti ha dicho
que se votará definitivamente esta
destitución el próximo martes
bueno y a corto plazo se ve alguna
solución a la crisis que vive el país es
decir el gobierno ha mostrado
disposición para solucionar los
requerimientos de los indígenas
bueno es precisamente este punto si bien
y en tanto se realiza una reunión el día
de ayer donde
representantes de organizaciones
indígenas y el ejecutivo nacional se
reúnen el día de hoy se conoce una de
las primeras resoluciones de los
movimientos indígenas hacia algunos
minutos la conaie ha confirmado que se
ha creado una comisión de las bases
indígenas para tratar las 10 demandas
del gobierno pero han ratificado que el
día de hoy ha sido considerado como una
minga nacional de descanso y se producen
las asambleas populares por parte de las
organizaciones indígenas por el
presidente de la república ha dicho que
a pesar de levantar el estado de
decisión si se produce un nuevo
levantamiento de violencia él podría de
nuevo declarar el estado de decisión y
se producen este tipo de mingas
populares porque es aquí donde se
reciben donaciones se realizan alimentos
para apoyar así a los movimientos
indígenas pero ellos saben que el debate
se realizará el próximo martes y han
dicho que seguirán apoyando las
paralizaciones en ecuador'